la amniocentesis es un procedimiento que
les permite a los médicos detectar o
descartar problemas en la salud de los
bebés mucho antes de su nacimiento en el
útero el bebé está rodeado del líquido
amniótico que proporciona protección y
alimento
las células del bebé se encuentran
flotando en el líquido lo que les
proporciona a los médicos material
genético para su evaluación en la
amniocentesis el médico tomará una
muestra del líquido para evaluar
trastornos genéticos específicos y
defectos de nacimiento
la amniocentesis por lo general se hace
en el segundo trimestre de embarazo
entre la semana 15 y 18 generalmente se
les ofrece a las mujeres con
determinados factores de riesgo mujeres
de 35 años de edad o mayores lo que
aumenta el riesgo de trastornos
cromosomáticos como el síndrome de dawn
un embarazo o niño anterior con algún
defecto de nacimiento análisis de sangre
o ultrasonido que sugiere un defecto de
nacimiento como síndrome de down o
defectos del tubo neural o un
antecedente familiar de trastornos
genéticos como fibrosis cística la
amniocentesis también puede ser
realizada en el tercer trimestre por las
siguientes razones para determinar si
debiera ser necesario un parto prematuro
cuando los pulmones del bebé están lo
suficientemente maduros para
diagnosticar una infección uterina o
para controlar la anemia en un bebé con
compatibilidad rh
para comenzar el procedimiento el médico
usará ultrasonido para crear una imagen
del feto y estructuras cercanas en la
pantalla de una computadora mientras
mira la imagen el médico puede elegir un
lugar seguro para insertar la aguja el
médico puede administrarle una inyección
de anestesia local para adormecer la
superficie del abdomen en donde se va a
insertar la aguja de la amniocentesis
el médico mirará cuidadosamente el
monitor ultrasonido para evitar el
contacto con la placenta o el bebé luego
introducirá la delgada aguja a través de
la pared abdominal en el útero y en el
saco amniótico
extraerá una pequeña muestra del líquido
amniótico
quitará la aguja y cubrirá el sitio con
una venda su cuerpo fabricará el líquido
adicional para reemplazar el que se
extrajo
el médico seguirá observando el
ultrasonido para verificar que los
latidos del corazón del feto sean
normales y que el bebé tolero bien el
procedimiento es posible que sienta
leves ganas de defecar o presión en el
abdomen inferior durante aproximadamente
24 horas después del procedimiento se le
aconsejará a evitar el estrés físico
como ejercicio enérgico alzamientos
quedarse de pie durante un tiempo
prolongado y actividad sexual